wir sind in berlin es arschkalt und
heute machen janisch und ich einen
spaziergang wir zeigen euch unterwegs
typische straßenzeichen die ihr in
deutschland sieht los geht's über diese
ampel sehen wir zwei schilder das obere
schild ist ein vorfahr zeichen es heißt
achtung vorfahrt das heißt dass die
andere straße vorfahrt hat und wenn die
ampel aus ist muss man die anderen
zuerst fahren lassen
diese reihe darf nur dann fahren wenn es
kein auto gibt das hier fährt darunter
das zeichen das blaue zeichen mit dem
weißen pfeil heiß hier darf man nur
geradeaus fahren und rechts abbiegen
nicht links
dieses zeichen was aussieht wie ein
viereckiges spiegel heißt vorfahrt das
vortrag solchen zeigt an dass die
menschen die auf dieser straße fahren
vorfahrt haben das heißt wenn die ampel
nicht funktioniert dann können sie
fahren und die anderen müssen waren
dieses zeichen mit dem roten kreis und
dem weißen strich heißt einfahrt
verboten
hier darfst du nicht reinfahren die
einzigen die hier fahren dürfen sind die
tramps so sieht ein typisches
straßenzeichen in berlin aus hier trifft
die danziger straße auf die pappelallee
das grüne haar im gelben kreis steht für
haltestelle hier ist eine haltestelle
wenn ihr dieses zeichen seht könnt ihr
in einen bus oder eine tram einsteigen
dieses schild das kreuz mit rot und blau
heißt absolutes halteverbot das absolute
halteverbot heißt hier darf man nicht
stehen bleiben nicht einmal für eine
minute und nicht mal um eine person
rauszulassen oder reinzulassen
der weiße pfeil zeigt an in welche
richtung das halteverbot gilt hier an
diesem bürgersteig darf man nicht halten
niemals und zu keiner zeit
jetzt wird's kompliziert denn wir wären
nicht in deutschland wenn es nicht noch
5000 sonderregeln gäbe
jetzt sehen wir ein absolutes
halteverbotsschild mit ausnahmen
dieses schild zeigt an dass es auf dem
seitenstreifen ein absolutes halteverbot
gibt allerdings nur von montag bis
freitag von 9 bis 12 uhr
allerdings gibt es ausnahmen man darf
beladen und entladen meiendorf
einsteigen und aussteigen auf den
seitenstreifen
dort darf man auch taten
allerdings nur mit parkschein oder
bewohner ausweis für zone 43 von montags
bis freitags die uhrzeiten können wir
leider nicht lesen
hier hat jemand keinen bewohner ausweis
und keinen tag schein sondern hat einen
zettel im auto hinterlassen
vin im spätkauf bin gleich wieder da
dieses schild heißt man muss rechts
abbiegen
außer fahrräder die sind frei und dürfen
fahren wohin sie wollen
diese haltestelle gibt es nur zwischen
23 und 7 uhr
sie ist nur für nachtbusse sonst
tagsüber passiert hier nichts
endlich ein schild auf dem auch steht
was es heißt einbahnstraße heißt dass es
auf dieser straße nur eine bahn gibt das
heißt man darf nur in eine richtung
fahren nämlich in die richtung des
weißen files aber fahrräder dürfen in
beide richtungen fahren
das schild mit dem ausrufezeichen ist
vermutlich international bekannt als
achtungszeichen
hier wird vor einer gefahr gewarnt
nämlich vor straßenschäden und vor nicht
mehr lesbar gehweg schäden
das werden wir jetzt mal untersuchen
wir suchen immer noch nach den gehweg
schäden da ist einer da ist noch einer
fast wäre ich gestolpert gut dass ich
gewarnt wurde
straßenschäden haben wir jetzt hier noch
nicht gefunden aber das ist eine
typische alte straße in berlin und auch
in anderen städten in deutschland das
nennt sich kopfsteinpflaster das ist
schon sehr alt und es wird einfach immer
heute noch behalten weil es so schön
aussieht oder sind löcher hier haben wir
nun einen echten straßen schaden
entdeckt ein loch im kopfsteinpflaster
nicht so angenehm hier mit dem fahrrad
her zu fahren
hier hat jemand auf kreative weise nach
weihnachten seinen tannenbaum entsorgt
in wohngegenden in deutschland gibt es
oft tempo-30-zonen in tempo-30-zonen
darf man nur 30 km h fahren
damit man auf kinder aufpasst und nicht
so viel krach macht dieses zeichen zeigt
an dass die tempo 30 zone hier zu ende
ist
falls ihr mal nach berlin zieht dann
überlegt euch gut ob ihr hier ein auto
haben wollt denn es ist super schwierig
in berlin einen parkplatz zu finden
es ist fast immer überall voll und wenn
ein freier parkplatz da ist sowie da
hinten dann ist es meistens einen
anwohnerparkplatz dieses schild zeigt
dass die brücke hier nur drei meter 90
hoch ist janosch du warst mal lkw fahrer
hast du schon mal so ein zeichen
übersehen
ja das habe ich einmal in ingolstadt in
bayern stand ich plötzlich von einem
mittelalterlichen stadttor und meine
einschätzung nach wäre es zu klein zu
niedrig für mich aber dann dachte ich
mir und die hätten sich was dabei
gedacht warum steht das plötzlich mitten
auf der straße also habe ich versucht da
vorsichtig durch zu fahren und bin
tatsächlich stecken geblieben ganz
schrecklich mittendrin stecken geblieben
und dann habe ich mit ach und krach und
mit lärm zurückgesetzt und teile von der
mauer abgebrochen und bin abgehauen und
ich dachte die leute würden mit mir
schimpfen und mich schlagen wollen
aber sie lachten sich nur kaputt
gallianis jetzt wissen wir dass solche
schilder sehr nützlich sind
das war unser video über verkehrszeichen
in berlin
jetzt führen wir unsere finger und
unsere füße nicht mehr und gehen rein
wenn ihr lust habt abonniert easy german
und klickt auf diese klingel dann
bekommt ihr immer eine benachrichtigung
wenn ein neues video draußen ist
außerdem freuen wir uns sehr
ein like und einen kommentar und
unterstützt unser projekt bike action
liebe grüße und bis bald